JEN PERSON: This
week, we're talking
about Persistent
Disk, BigQuery and SAP
apps, and AutoML Translation.
I'm Jen, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
When it comes to managing
block storage data
protection in the cloud,
everyone makes trade-offs
based on their situation.
To make sure you're ready with
the backup and recovery plan
that your situation
needs, we've got a variety
of features in Persistent Disk.
Features like snapshot
locality, scheduled snapshots,
and automatic
replication between zones
for regional persistent disk.
BigQuery is a dream come
true for massive data
sets in machine learning models.
And now, we're
making complex tasks
like data quality
checking part of BigQuery
with the beta launch
of scripting and stored
procedures.
Before, steps had
to be run manually.
But now you can script
directly in BigQuery.
Hello, local variables!
And even save your script as a
stored procedure, which you can
share and run again next month.
Building great cloud
solutions is more than
building your perfect
enterprise data warehouse.
Companies rely on
internal data systems
to operate systems
like SAP apps.
And often, those systems need to
work with your cloud solutions
to discover new insights.
So we've got an
integration guide
that will walk you
through data replication
from SAP applications to Google
BigQuery with existing tooling.
Our Translation API got a
series of updates this week.
Most notably, AutoML Translation
is now generally available.
So anyone can build
domain-specific translation
into their workflows.
Translate your corporate
lingo with the use
of a glossary or three,
which you can apply
manually or automatically.
Talk about synergy.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.